i
hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en esta oportunidad nos
acompaña el líder opositor venezolano
juan guaidó quien en enero de 2019 era
proclamado como presidente interino de
su país tras desconocer al nuevo mandato
que comenzaba por aquel momento nicolás
maduro su presidencia interina ha sido
reconocida por alrededor de 50 países de
todo el mundo y a más de un año y medio
de aquel momento que marcó al país vamos
a dialogar sobre la actualidad
venezolana también sobre su rol como
líder opositor una figura clave en el
país entre otros temas juan guaidó
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
la entrevista de france 24
muy buenas tardes muchísimas gracias por
la invitación no por favor es un placer
para nosotros señor wide o para el 6 de
diciembre han sido convocadas las
elecciones parlamentarias en venezuela y
en la oposición ya hay posturas
antagónicas no respecto de participar o
no de hecho usted junto a decenas de
partidos que tienen representación
parlamentaria no lo harán sin embargo
otros opositores sí lo harán como por
ejemplo henrique capriles que llamaron a
participar estas posturas divergentes no
al interior de la oposición venezolana
considera usted que debilitan sus
objetivos de quitar a maduro del poder
miren lo que está planteado para
diciembre es lamentablemente es un
paredón de estiramiento hoy por ejemplo
si yo quisiera ser candidato no pudiera
por no solamente inhabilitación también
persecución y legalización de más de
cuatro partidos políticos que por cierto
reunir el 80% de los parlamentarios en
venezuela lamentablemente y tienden a
ser más ruidosas las diferencias pero 37
partidos de que hacen bien alternativa
mejor si acá en venezuela 105
organizaciones la sociedad civil hemos
decidido no participar por ser un fraude
lo digo así también el grupo
internacional de contacto la
organización de estados américanos
nuestros aliados y precisamente la lucha
es por lograr condiciones competitivas
para convertir el voto en una lucha hoy
el derecho al voto en venezuela es en sí
mismo una lucha para poder dirimir la
crisis humanitaria la crisis y la
pandemia que vive pero también entender
que venezuela y maduro hoy es está
señalada como criminal por delitos de
lesa humanidad
ahora como usted decía señor muchas
veces llama mucho más la atención lo que
son los altercados o las diferencias no
al interior tanto de partidos como de
sectores opositores pero como explica
que haya posiciones antagónicas no
teniendo en cuenta este factor en común
que tienen todos los opositores que es
quitar a maduro del poder
la diferencia está en la forma habremos
intentado al menos oremos hemos
construido mayoría el 90% del país
rechaza a maduro hoy está señalado como
criminal de lesa humanidad también
tienen recompensa por narcotráfico por
estar vinculado al narcotráfico en las
regiones grupos como el elenin de
disidencia de las farc por supuesto en
este proceso tiene un proceso
importante de movilización estamos
absolutamente de acuerdo en el que
estamos dando es de cómo básicamente en
este momento en venezuela lo que está
planteando diciembre de nuevo es un
fraude y hoy todos los partidos
políticos incluyendo primera noticia del
cual forma parte henrique capriles ha
dicho que no se puede participar en un
fraude por el contrario hay que luchar
por lograr condiciones que transformen
un evento electoral en una una solución
posible a la crisis y al conflicto en
venezuela
ahora voy a continuar un poco más con
las elecciones de diciembre luego ya
pasamos a otros temas como yo le decía
no henrique capriles otro líder opositor
no venezolano llama a participar en
estos comicios como ustedes bien
planteaban las diferencias son de forma
no de cómo encarar este objetivo de
quitar a maduro del poder usted cómo
evalúa posturas como las de capriles
mantuvo conversaciones con él
así que no solamente con enrique
manacorina todos los partidos políticos
hemos sostenido reunión y conversación
de nuevo
el 37 partir a decir todos los partidos
de la alternativa democrática en
venezuela estamos absolutamente
alineados y no solamente en rechazar y
después usar el forado sino enfrentar a
maduro que luego del informe que produjo
la misión de verificación de hechos por
delitos de lesa humanidad y que señalan
a maduro como un criminal de esa manera
también nos obliga a unirnos nos obliga
a enfrentar esta tragedia cuando la
intención de la dictadura según esa
misma comisión es aniquilar a la
alternativa democrática ha dicho esto
por uno de los relatores de ese informe
así que hoy más que nunca estamos
obligados como venezolanos pero también
como sociedad global no como ser
espectadores de una tragedia en
venezuela hoy estamos obligados a tomar
acción por la dignidad humana por el
respeto a los derechos humanos y por
lograr una solución al conflicto que
vive venezuela ahora señor guayo hay
analistas e incluso seguidores suyos no
que hablan de una suerte de debilitación
de su figura como líder opositor que
responde a quienes plantean
esto desgaste en su liderazgo a sectores
de la sociedad también que quizás no
están de acuerdo con sus acciones pero
que si son opositores a nicolás maduro
bueno los invito a leer el informe de
verificación de hechos delitos de lesa
humanidad hemos resistido a tortura
asesinato político persecución censura
etnocidios en el caso del arco minero el
financiamiento de la dictadura a través
de oro manchado de sangre que extraen
ilegalmente desplazando indígenas pero
también destruyendo el amazonas
venezolano hoy el desgaste es a
venezuela el 70 por ciento del pib se
destruyó en el país durante 7 años hay
5.1 millones de refugiados que son
indicadores de países en guerra la
guerra era una dictadura en contra
venezolanos que resistimos de manera
firme de manera determinada a ese
proceso en el momento de ser
complacientes con una dictadura de
exculpar los de alguna manera porque
está pasando en venezuela no tiene que
ver nada de una posición con un
dirigente u otro no tiene que ver con
natura del proceso de desgaste de la
sociedad por lo cual la dictadura sigue
ahí y sigue ahí porque asesina tortura
persigue pero ha encontrado una sociedad
luchando por su dignidad y su democracia
ahora una de las últimas noticias no
también que trascendió a nivel mundial y
que llegaba desde venezuela tuvo que ver
con el indulto que firmó en nicolás
maduro el mes pasado con el que le
otorgaba libertad a más de 100 presos
políticos hablamos de líderes sociales
políticos opositores periodistas
representantes de distintos sectores de
la sociedad
henrique capriles incluso el manifesto
que habían sido negociaciones que había
mantenido el a nivel de personal usted
señor guay 2 estaba al tanto de esas
negociaciones y por otro lado
preguntarle qué crees que es lo que
motivó realmente a maduro a firmar este
decreto
bien en la única mediación que hemos
llevado adelante formal es a través del
reino de noruega un mediador calificado
ha tenido éxitos experiencia a nivel
internacional las discusiones personales
de enrique con otro dirigente
exactamente con la dictadura no han sido
avaladas por el parlamento
y no tenemos conocimiento ahora maduro
reconoce la existencia no de siempre
esto ya continúan 328 presos políticos
civiles y militares
tenía conocimiento de todo por supuesto
el dictador maduro del informe que
estaba estaba trabajando desde la
comisión de verificación de hechos de la
comisión de derechos humanos de las
naciones unidas y trató de una manera
digamos implementar esta medida para
suavizar su imagen también lo hizo por
cierto en 2018 y en su momento lideró
casi a 50 lo que es el reconocimiento
insisto a la tortura a los presos
políticos a la persecución a lo que
produjo en definitiva ese documento que
la intención del régimen de madures
aniquilar a la alternativa y algo
importante
ese informe viene a ratificar la
resistencia de la sociedad venezolana
ante estos crímenes pero también no es
no es un conflicto entre partes
interesadas por asumir el poder es una
crisis por democracia es una crisis por
respeto a los derechos humanos es una
crisis por sobrevivir a una una pandemia
pero también a una emergencia
humanitaria compleja en este momento en
venezuela para que tengan una idea
la tasa de mortalidad del sector salud
de personas del 30 por ciento eso habla
del deterioro del sistema de salud
nacional donde apenas 54 por ciento no
llega a agua por tubería entonces aquí
la realidad es la necesidad en este
momento de buscar una solución a la
crisis que vive venezuela
haciendo un balance no del tiempo de
transcurrido desde aquel mes de enero de
2019 cuáles creen que hayan sido sus
principales logros de su gobierno
interino y también las deudas pendientes
hace autocrítica respecto de algo
si te pregunta lo primero que el haber
conseguido mayoría articulado a los
mayores sectores de la nativa al haber
descartado una silla por ejemplo en la
organización de estados americanos para
aprender la demostración venezuela pero
también en nicaragua y cuba también el
haber protegido los activos de la
república del saqueo de la dictadura en
este momento hay un juicio
por extrema o verde de una persona
ligada a maduro por lado dinero que
segunda 12
con 700 millones de dólares calculó en
300.000 millones la estafa a la nación
en este momento pero también la pregunta
los errores asumidos y que tenemos que
corregir es que más falta para lograr la
transición en venezuela hemos ofrecido
garantías en un proceso de una ley desde
el parlamento de ley de amnistía y
garantías de reconciliación el
levantamiento progresivo de las
sanciones en el marco para la transición
para precisamente que todos los actores
políticos puedan participar en elección
presidencial y parlamentaria libre que
ofrezca garantías de estabilidad
democrática en venezuela la
interlocución con la fuerza armada la
necesidad de la presentación de un plan
país
la organización intermedia una parte
pero también de persecución son parte de
las variables de donde hemos analizado
lo bueno lo malo donde hemos analizado
qué más falta en esa dirección para
lograr una transición y recuperar la
democracia venezuela
a menos minutos señor mayor pero quiero
preguntarle para finalizar en qué
momento están de esta lucha que llevan a
cabo contra el gobierno de maduro donde
están parados exactamente qué protección
hace hacia el futuro
manolo tiene un 90% el rechazo interno
en venezuela es su único aliado irán en
este momento a quién le compra gasolina
y arma de manera muy costosa tiene
vinculación con el narcotráfico y el
terrorismo está señalada por delitos de
lesa humanidad y a pesar de todo eso
venezuela a pesar de que hoy el sueldo
mínimo del venezolano es de un dólar al
mes de pobreza al menos un dólar al día
hoy es el sueldo de un mes del
venezolano estamos aquí resistiendo pero
también
construyendo un futuro chile para
nuestras generaciones por venir y lo
importante es que no nos vamos a detener
hasta el renacimiento deben tener una
elección presidencial y parlamentaria
libre realmente es el venezolano y en el
isa vamos a seguir trabajando con todos
los actores mejor armada los factores
disidentes del régimen
de maduro pero también ofrece días para
poder unir al país para poder sanar a
venezuela y ver rescatar
a venezuela juan guaidó muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en la
entrevista de france 24
muchas gracias por favor a nuestra
audiencia la invitamos como siempre a
quedarse con nosotros porque hay mucho
más en el resto de nuestra programación
y recuerden que pueden volver a ver esta
entrevista hay muchas otras en france24
punto com
[Música]
bien